I might owe you a little bit of an
apology sorry about that sorry for
trolling you in the thumbnail you know
what you think to yourself you know what
the reviews gonna be like because of the
thumbnail well here we go
how did we get here what happened what
happened to Star Wars what happened
where are we
what weird alternate dimension am I in
let's review star wars episode 9 the
rise of Skywalker sounds epic right you
just wait so this is a spoiler free
review don't worry about that in that
it's gonna be a little harder to review
spoiler video will probably be a lot
more fun more interesting be here for
that so anyhow let's uh let's talk about
it so Star Wars Episode nine is a
four-hour movie they crushed into two
and a half hours because it feels like
this movie probably should have been a
lot longer but it's also part three at
the Disney Star Wars trilogy supposedly
the last of the core movies the core
saga that we're gonna get end of the
Skywalker saga whatever you want to say
I'm gonna get right to what I like
through this movie I like the nostalgic
stuff sure I mean it's cheap as hell
they're going for the member berry soup
right there whenever they can you feel
like they're just gonna be like Oh
remember this I remember remember that I
remember they're not member enough
Williams pick it up then a very familiar
John Williams score will start swelling
at the opportune moment it makes you
like aha nostalgia which whatever you
want to say about Star Wars movies the
ones you like the ones you don't if
there's a core one through nine if the
episodes one through nine even if you
don't like the episodes John Williams in
my opinions never the weak part so I
enjoyed the power of nostalgia coming
back to me because it's a very powerful
thing I enjoyed the member berries until
they started getting a little heavy and
it's like okay come on I mean I know now
I see it it's like I like the puppet
show but I'm seeing the person behind
the curtain and it's it's compromising
the effect other than that it's not a
lot of liked in this movie to be honest
with you I know you know what there is
this new commander there's this new
commander in the first order I liked him
but again damage control they made Hux a
little [ __ ] and so they're like we need
someone the audience will fear we got to
bring this other guy on board if you
like more than a few things in rise of
Skywalker is damaged
for the last Jedi so it's really hard to
tell where the damage control ends and
the actual vision of the movie they
wanted to make begins I'm not just
talking about the fact they're like
Schnucks dead [ __ ] alright let's bring
in Palpatine which I know they are JJ
Abrams have said no that was the plan
from the beginning to bring Palpatine in
[ __ ] I thought it was [ __ ]
before I saw the movie now that I've
seen the movies no way you're gonna
convince me otherwise it's not just that
there are a couple of bits of dialogue
in here I was like we had different
information a couple years ago I mean
it's part three of this new trilogy so
at a point you got to look back and be
like okay where did it go wrong you know
what what wrong turns were made but on
the other hand you got to judge the
movie on its own merits as its own
episode but we're in the concluding
chapter of a trilogy that had a
stormtrooper that turned good that's
actually an arc I'd never seen in any of
the movies I've seen people who lived on
desert planets who become Jedi have seen
that a couple times I've seen good
pilots I've seen scoundrels never seen a
stormtrooper turned good what did they
do with that not much thought they would
but they didn't is kept him the friend
the sidekick because you know everyone
needs a sidekick even when john boyega's
cast is him john boyega's a good actor
what are you doing wasting him I'll say
that the actors all the actors do fine
for what they're given Adam drivers good
in the movie he does the best with what
he has but I don't feel like he was
really given much to do in here there
are a couple moments where he could have
been given more to do but in the end now
cuz I feel like the intrigue that they
feel is driving this whole thing is the
intrigue of will they won't they hashtag
reloj I don't care if they [ __ ] or not
let's save the galaxy but at a point I
was like this movie feels really choppy
because you know the Star Wars wipes
those fades that happen because
essentially it's a location change at a
point it was just fade fade wipe wipe
transition this movie has to have the
most amount of Star Wars wipes that
sounds totally like a toilet paper they
had so many transitions in succession
it's just because it's just speed
running you through this plot lots
pretty generous I don't know scavenger
hunt I mean even the movie starts out in
the opening crawl you're like oh that's
that's some information okay where some
stuff has happened then the movie starts
out with a situation wrapping up and
you're like actually here's what's gonna
happen if it doesn't already exist there
will be a prequel book that comes out
that fills in those gaps because busy
but I was like okay maybe the movie just
starts out a little choppy but the
choppiness stays with the movie for
quite some time doesn't help there's not
a lot of intrigue at all I mean anytime
there could be intrigue
it's like someone pops into frame to
explain something it's like oh what
would they need with that oh just
popping into frame okay let's go do the
thing then but what should we do just go
to that planet go there all right now we
know it doesn't feel like there's an
organic unraveling of information as
much as there is just exposition vomit
did you see that trailer that one I mean
I'm not gonna play it in case you didn't
see the trailer but in this trailer you
know that trailer but in the trailer
there's this voice that gives kylo Ren
information and you're like you're just
you're just gonna answer that just like
that people and characters in the movie
kind of just always do that well I have
an intriguing unraveling of information
when you can just you know save time and
then after that make with the video game
plot I'm not talking like good video
game plot because it's like a scavenger
hunt video game plot all right we have
to go to this planet who are we looking
for we're looking for this person this
person is like hey I'm that person but I
don't actually have the thing you're
looking for that person might alright
let's go over there alright I need to
think yeah you need a thing but you need
me to get the thing to get you the thing
it's just an unraveling of 90s video
game play I know there have been some
great video game plots in the 90s but
it's the formula it's the format it's
the best I can describe it also are they
friends are Poe Finn and Rey are they
actually friends one thing I noticed in
this movie you look at Return of the
Jedi you even look at Anakin and obi-wan
by the time Revenge of the Sith happens
at least in the first part yeah they're
bickering obi-wan rolls his eyes a few
times shakes his head maybe but you can
tell they do have a friendship there's a
kinship there everyone returning the
Jedi's like all kumbaya all the time one
time han Solo kind of exploded on Leia
could you tell Luke is that he you could
tell you I'm sorry I'm sorry rise a
Skywalker they just they bicker and
argue over each other all the time that
kind of arguing that just gets your
anxiety up you're like God okay you all
can't wait for this to end too huh
sweetie another thing this movie didn't
do so great is illustrate the threat
level you know threat fear of danger
that's kind of what makes an adventure
thrilling but there's a scene worth of
running through this place just
massacring stormtroopers bull's-eyes
every time no need to take cover ever
which tells the audience there's no need
to worry which means no threat
means no thrill which means boring I
mean I love a good god mode code myself
but once in a while don't make it the
movie ray is so Opie in this movie she's
so she is so overpowered she's more
powerful here than you've ever seen her
which it's been like a year I guess I
hear I hear online that has been a year
but she does some stuff in here where
you're like where did you learn that how
did how I'm not talking like swinging at
a lightsaber and she's good at fighting
herself I'm talking [ __ ] how almost
disappointing for me he's just the third
act at a point just felt ridiculous only
word I can use to describe it as
ridiculous it's like Abrams was like we
got to do really big stuff let's do big
stuff it's like this movie or at least
the third act was made by someone who
likes Star Wars ish things but doesn't
really know the Star Wars lore there are
rules in Star Wars look I can always say
so much with spoiler phrase so I'm just
gonna give you the gist I genuinely
think if you love the force awakens and
the last Jedi still if it just hit you
and you just love the movies I think
he'll probably enjoy Rises Skywalker
it's the concluding chapter of that
trilogy that you love and that's why I
say this with a heavy heart but I really
do mean it I just legitimately driving
home from the screening this was the
thing in my head and this is just real
the rise of Skywalker is my least
favorite of the nine core saga films I
saw some people say this movie's bold
like it had some bold decisions III
didn't see anything bold in here there's
nothing bold about this movie there's a
difference between bold and desperate
but maybe when this movie comes on
Disney Plus I'll fast forward to the
good scenes I can't think of any I don't
know any scene in this movie I'll
actually fast forward it to even the
lightsaber fights bored me I guess
that's the hardest part is I just I felt
nothing in the movie I was watching it
I'm like it feels like a sci-fi movie
just feels like another sci-fi movie
which is never what Star Wars ever felt
like Sorrows always had that sense of
lore building or character building
moving towards something you know what
they're moving towards in this movie and
by the engines it feels like oh you were
moving towards damage control that was
sloppily executed Congrats there are a
couple things there are three things in
particular I could think if I'm like
beating a dead horse now I'm just saying
I'm not gonna remember rise of Skywalker
and t-minus one day ya already forgot I
so star
where's the rise of Skywalker have you
seen it what did you think about it are
you looking forward to it and list the
Star Wars movies favorite to least
favorite I know I asked that a couple
years ago but they change over time but
whatever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]